[Music]
the apocalypse
doomsday the end of the world it's a
gloomy subject that many world religions
have approached
in christianity the last book of the
bible the book of revelation
contains a frightening vision of
cataclysmic events
demonic horsemen and even a few
multi-eyed bible accurate angels for
good measure
this book is without doubt the strangest
and most disturbing book in the whole
bible
so naturally it's a topic i had to cover
on this channel
you may have heard of the book of
revelation but may not be so familiar
with what actually happens in the book
for example where does the number 666
fit into all of it
if you're looking to learn more about
the biblical apocalypse well
you're in the right place i've crafted
together this handy introductory video
you never know when you might need it
before we start it's worth noting that
i'm going to examine the book of
revelation from a secular
non-religious perspective the book is
highly symbolic
and probably not meant to be taken
literally so at occasional moments
throughout the video i'll explain what
some of the symbolism may mean
using the interpretations of biblical
scholars disclaimer out the way
bring on the apocalypse the word
apocalypse itself
comes from the greek and it literally
means to uncover something
that's actually why it's called the book
of revelation it's all to do with
something being revealed
in this case the end of the world
there's a rich history of these
apocalypses in the old testament
but they don't necessarily have anything
to do with the end times sometimes
they're just these
startling visions of the otherworldly
like a glimpse of god's throne in the
book of ezekiel
or a dream featuring four strange beasts
in the book of daniel
the book of revelation is from the
perspective of a guy called john
we don't know much about this character
it's not the same john who baptized
people in the jordan
nor is it the same person who wrote the
fourth gospel no
this is an entirely different john it
turns out that there's a lot of people
called john in the bible
in fact some scholars believe that this
particular john might not have existed
at all
like most books in the bible the book of
revelation was written
and edited by anonymous authors and so
john may have been a pseudonym
scholars say that the oldest part of the
book was probably written around 65 ce
during the reign of emperor nero and may
have reached its final form
at around 95 ce during the reign of
emperor domitian
both of these emperors particularly the
first one emprenero were known for their
brutal persecutions of early christians
a significant detail in order to
understand the worldview behind the book
of revelation
it was written in a frightening time for
these first christians and their
anxieties were captured on the pages
containing a frightening collection of
visions about the end of the world
let's turn to the contents of the vision
itself
we start off in the idyllic greek island
of patmos where our main character jon
has been exiled
behind him he suddenly hears a booming
voice calling his name
he turns around only to see a spectral
figure bathed in bright light
surrounded by seven golden lamp stands
this unnamed person
who some believe to be jesus himself has
a very strange appearance
he is enrobed in white with eyes like
fire and protruding from his mouth is a
sharp
two-edged sword yes this description is
in the text and trust me
it's not the strangest we've yet to see
this strange figure tells jon to write
to the seven churches
dotted across the mediterranean to give
them a heads up about what's about to go
down
once he does so jon is immediately
whisked up into heaven
from there john gives a spectacular
account of everything he sees
in front of him is a giant throne with
24 smaller thrones surrounding it
the central throne is so bright
glistening like many precious stones
that he can't actually make out the
figure sitting on it but we can safely
assume that it's meant to be god himself
but his attention is quickly drawn to
four strange
multi-eyed beasts that are floating
around near the throne
although the bible calls them simply
living creatures you may already be
familiar with them as
bible accurate angels good friends of
the channel at this point
here's a description he gives of them
around the throne
and on each side of the throne are four
living creatures
full of eyes in front and behind the
first living creature is like a lion
the second living creature is like an ox
the third living creature
with a face like a human face and the
fourth living creature
like a flying eagle all four living
creatures
each of them with six wings are full of
eyes all around
and inside day and night without ceasing
they sing
a very strange description indeed a
winged lion
ox humanoid and eagle covered in eyes
from head to toe
and singing praises to god eternally but
this point you may have already watched
my video on bible accurate angels and
you may be familiar with these creatures
in the book of ezekiel in the old
testament
they feature in a magnificent vision the
hebrew prophet gives of god's heavenly
throne
in that video i suggested that they
likely developed from the mesopotamian
cherubim
known as lamasu sadly however there are
none of those wheels with eyes
known as ophenim to be found in this
account
not much else is said about these four
eldritch hybrids other than this
although some have interpreted their
multi eyes as a symbol of god's
all-seeing nature
others see it to be deliberately creepy
now i don't know about you
but i certainly see why they think this
after his description of the four living
creatures
next before jon comes another strange
beast it is described as looking like a
lamb
although it has seven horns and seven
eyes
because of course it does it also looks
like it's been slain
because of this many associate this
being with jesus
who is sometimes called the lamb of god
whatever it is
the lamb creature holds in its hooves a
large scroll with seven wax seals
with this the apocalypse is truly
underway
when the first seal is broken out comes
a man on a white horse
wielding a bow and wearing a crown this
is the embodiment of conquest the first
of the four horsemen of the apocalypse
seal two is broken and out comes a
horseman a strider red horse
holding a large sword this is the
horseman of war
kinda similar to conquest in my opinion
but whatever
cl3 is broken and out comes a rider on a
black horse
holding weighing scales this is the
horseman of
famine finally the fourth seal is broken
and out comes a rider on a pale horse
the embodiment of death itself with four
of the seven seals broken
the lamb creature hands the four
horsemen a quarter of the earth's
population to destroy
either through violence famine
pestilence or death
okay so there are three seals left and
three unpleasant events
left to transpire luckily seal five is a
bit of a dud
nothing really happens other than the
souls of the martyrs are given nice
white robes
and told to wait around a bit for the
final judgment but when seal six is open
things get really nasty for people on
earth no sooner than the seal is broken
and there is a giant earthquake an
earthquake so large that
quote every mountain and island was
removed from its place
if we take this literally this kind of
earthquake would far surpass the
magnitudes of the biggest recorded
earthquakes
like the 1960 valladiva earthquake in
chile that measured
9.5 on the richter scale such a large
earthquake would be particularly bad
news for anyone living on tectonic fault
lines
as well as a cataclysmic earthquake the
sixth seal would also make the sky turn
black
were it to happen perpetual darkness
would be devastating for earth
especially for plant life which requires
sunlight to perform photosynthesis
interestingly such events have actually
happened before and are often caused by
major volcanic eruptions
in 536 ce during a period of european
history
aptly known as the dark ages a giant
volcanic eruption believed to be from
indonesia
triggered what is known as a volcanic
winter this is when vast quantities of
volcanic ash
enter the atmosphere dimming the
sunlight and causing rapid cooling
writing from constantinople in 536
byzantine historian procopius wrote that
quote during this year a most dreaded
portent took place
for the sun gave forth its light without
brightness
and it seemed exceedingly like the sun
in eclipse
for the beams it shed were not clear
other contemporary writers as far away
as ireland have attested to the same
extreme weather indicating that this
phenomenon may have been widespread at
the time
and that the earth was indeed in a
volcanic winter if giant earthquakes and
volcanic winters were not enough
the sixth seal also describes how quote
the stars of the sky fell to earth
now if an actual star collided with the
earth then that really began over as
earth would be engulfed into a much
larger ball
of flame and plasma it is more likely
therefore that the author is referring
to a meteor shower
often these are quite harmless earth
orbits through many space rocks every
day
resulting in beautiful shooting stars
things get dangerous however when these
rocks are big enough to not fully burn
up in the atmosphere
one such occasion was the tunguska event
in 1908 where a meteoroid of an
estimated 100 meters
landed in eastern siberia flattening the
surrounding forest of up to 2
100 square kilometers that's 830 square
miles
being in siberia the land was sparsely
populated so only three people were
believed to have been killed had this
landed on a city in 1908
then it would have been truly
catastrophic seal six is pretty brutal
mega earthquakes perpetual darkness and
meteorite impacts
but there is one more seal left the
seventh seal
fortunately just like seal five seal
seven doesn't bring too much calamity
the book simply says
quote there was a silence in heaven for
about half an hour
perhaps the multi-eyed living creatures
from earlier can finally get a break
from singing god's praises
you would have thought that the seven
seals were enough to end earth
more bad things are on the way almost as
soon as the seventh seal is opened
out come seven angels holding seven
trumpets
now you've probably noticed that the
number seven appears quite a bit
in the book of revelation seven golden
lamp stands seven seals
now seven trumpets the number seven is a
significant one throughout the bible
for example in the book of genesis it
reportedly took seven days to create the
universe
in the ancient world this number seven
was often regarded as the number of
completion the idea that the number
seven was a special number
carried on into later christian
tradition where you also get the seven
deadly sins
which by the way is another topic i've
covered on the channel
forget what you've seen about cute
angels with sweet little trumpets
these seven trumpets are about to
destroy the earth
it's about to get dark and in the case
of trumpet fall quite literally
let's quickly rattle off what each
trumpet does trumpet one causes fire and
hail to rain down on the earth
wildfires soon rage on the planet and a
third of earth's vegetation gets burnt
up
trumpet two sounds and a great
mountain-sized object falls into the sea
turning a third of the oceans into blood
it also kills a third of the innocent
sea creatures
which is pretty sad trumpet three plays
and a star
falls from heaven and lands onto the
earth's rivers the star is even given a
name
wormwood this is actually a type of
semi-poisonous herb
also known as mugwort which makes sense
in the book of revelation
because wormwood contaminates all the
world's fresh water supplies
making it bitter and toxic trumpet four
toots and the third of the sun goes out
shrouding the planet in darkness we seem
to have already had this one already
back in the sixth seal this discrepancy
has led some scholars to suggest that a
different author is writing here
perhaps unaware of the previous
destruction wrought by the seven seals
trumpet five in my opinion is the
strangest of them all
an angel descends to earth with a big
key the key opens a large trap tall to a
bottomless pit
and out of the pit comes a thick black
smoke that eclipses whatever sunlight
was left
then out of the dense fumes emerged
giant locusts that swarm and cause
plagues all over the earth
now these aren't just any giant locusts
they are book of revelation giant
locusts
and so they're given a very disturbing
description here goes
they have human faces and long flowing
hair they wear armor and have little
crowns on their head
oh also they have lions teeth and giant
scorpion stingers
because again why not these creatures
are given the instruction to sting
people
but not enough to kill them in fact it
says that people will be unable to die
during this time
no matter how much they might wish to
this is absolute
nightmare fuel but there are still two
trumpets to go trumpet six is sounded
and four angels are released to kill a
third of humankind
all of whom helped to exterminate a
third of human's population
the final trumpet trumpet seven doesn't
cause any destruction
instead there's a little hymn for those
in heaven and a few flashes of lightning
here and there but no major destruction
on earth
at this point i'd imagine that the world
is practically unlivable
i'm starting to think that calling this
video a survival guide
might seem a bit pointless the water has
turned into blood
things are on fire there's no sunlight
anymore and there are giant manticore
looking locusts
stinging people the book of revelation
has really gone to town in painting the
most disastrous picture possible
believe it or not there are still yet
more troubles to come but in the form of
three giant monsters
up first is a giant red dragon with
seven heads
and ten horns so two of the seven heads
have two horns each the ten of the
dragon
is so large that when it sweeps it
apparently casts a third of the stars
down
we find out that the red dragon is satan
himself
who is suddenly attacked and defeated by
the archangel michael
dragon satan gets booted out of heaven
and throws down to earth
and the land swallows him up after this
strange little episode
comes the main attraction the two
so-called beasts
the first beast comes out from the sea
this first beast has the shape of a
leopard
it's got feet like a bear and a mouth
like a lime it's got multiple heads
and no surprises that there are seven of
them like the dragon
it's got 10 horns with a diadem on each
of those horns
one of the heads however looks to be
wounded once coming up from the sea
this beast goes around bad-mouthing god
and saying all kinds of blasphemies the
survivors on earth
and yes apparently there are survivors
all start to worship this monster
then suddenly the earth opens up and
another strange beast
comes out from the ground compared with
the first beast the description is
lacking a bit all we get is that it has
two horns like a lamb but speaks like a
dragon
and that's really it this beast goes
around telling the inhabitants of earth
how great beast number one is and
performs a bunch of magic tricks to
prove it's legit
the character is later known as the
false prophet although you may be
familiar with the name used for it in
other christian texts
the antichrist literally meaning the
anti-messiah
so should you choose to believe in this
monster it's bad news for you
this beast goes around and writes a
specific number on the four heads of
idolatrous
the famous mark of the beast the number
666
what is significant about this number
666
well many biblical scholars have
suggested that it's a code
for the tyrannical emperor nero you see
in the classical world there was this
practice of assigning letters to numbers
it's known as gematria hebrew letters
had this system
too and if you spell out emprenero in
hebrew they add up to the number
six six six some of the oldest versions
of the book of revelation
like this papyrus manuscript found at
oxyrinkus in egypt
have the number 616 gemitrius still
works here just for a different spelling
of nero's name
interestingly the book of revelation
says that in order to buy and sell
things
you need to show the mark of the beast
as with today's currencies
roman coins often featured the head of
the head of state
in this case the emperor so in order to
barter and trade
you need to show the mark of the beast
i.e the emperor nero's face
on coinage this interpretation is
further supported by the greek word for
mark
as in mark of the beast which is haragma
and it's most commonly used to refer to
the imprinting of coins
what's the emperor nero got to do with
the beast well empreniero who ruled from
54
to 68 ce was responsible for a number of
infamous christian persecutions early
christians refused to worship the
emperor
who in the imperial cult was a divine
figure instead they held that their
exclusive belief was in god the god of
israel
this enraged many a roman emperor
especially nero
who attempted to persecute them out of
existence he even blamed the great fire
of rome
on the christians and contemporary
writers wrote harrowing accounts of all
the suffering this emperor inflicted
such as throwing christians to lions as
a result nera especially became a symbol
of evil
so when the book of revelation is
talking about people worshiping the
beast
it refers to the practice of worshiping
the emperor all this is done in code
those who bear the mark 666 in other
words nero will be condemned to suffer
for all eternity
whilst the earth is under the dominion
of these strange beasts slash roman
emperors
up in heaven the angels are preparing
the final phase of destruction
we've had seven seals seven trumpets and
now we've got
seven bowls these bowls are said to be
full of god's wrath
whatever that entails either way the
bowls work in a similar way to the seals
and trumpets
when they're poured onto the earth bad
things happen here we go again
final one this time bowl one is poured
onto the earth and painful swords and
boils form on all the people who wear
the mark of the beast on their forehead
bowl two causes the whole sea now to
turn into blood
no longer just a third of it bowl three
causes all the fresh water
the lakes and the rivers to turn to
blood yep lots of blood in this passage
balfour
causes the sun's heat to intensify
scorching people on earth badly
bowl 5 causes the kingdom of the beast
to go dark
and political instability ensues some
have seen this as a reference to the
fall of the roman empire
bowl six causes the river euphrates
that's in modern day iraq
to dry up later the world's armies all
assemble
and do battle at a place known as
armageddon fun fact
the hebrew word for armageddon is ha
megiddo referring to mount megiddo in
northern israel
over time ha megiddo shifted to
armageddon and because of the book of
revelation
it became another name for the
apocalypse bowl 7 is your classic book
of revelation business
lightning hailstones and a massive
earthquake which destroys the city of
babylon
however where babylon was the great city
of evil in the old testament
by the time of the new testament being
written the city of babylon had long
been deserted
having been conquered by the persians
some 500 years before
so instead many believe that babylon is
a reference to the capital city of the
empire
rome again it's another example of the
book of revelation speaking in code
after a third and final round of
devastation which
seems to me a tad excessive the vision
in the book of revelations begins to
near its end
in fact the whole thing wraps up pretty
quickly without much of a struggle
the first and second beast are captured
by the armies of god
and are kicked into quote a lake of fire
that burns with sulphur
which is probably a reference to hell
then the giant multi-headed dragon
which is satan is locked up in the pit
too and is sealed for 1 000 years
in this intermission jesus comes down to
rule the earth
until things pick up again well time
flies
1 000 years pass and satan is released
it's now time for the epic final
showdown or biblical proportions
however the serious finale of the bible
is a bit anti-climactic
all that happens is a shoot of fire zips
down from heaven and engulfs the evil
army
satan and all his monsters are cast into
the lake of fire and sulfur to join the
beasts
and his evil influence finally comes to
an end
the book of revelation draws to a close
and we get the bible's happy ending
a vision of something called the new
jerusalem it's a description of a
wondrous new city
made of solid gold our protagonist john
goes to great lengths to describe its
dimensions
and it turns out that the new jerusalem
is one giant
cube its length width and height are 12
000 stadia which is 2 220 kilometers
that's 1
380 miles in this city god jesus
all the do-gooders and all the
multi-eyed creatures live in perpetual
harmony
it is this vision of a strange sci-fi
construction
that the book of revelation closes with
and with it
the entire bible comes to an end
so without a doubt the book of
revelation is the strangest book in the
bible
finishing it off in a maelstrom of fire
earthquakes
eldritch creatures chaos and calamity if
such an event were to take place
it looks to be a pretty unpleasant
affair in such a complex and intricate
book of the bible i haven't managed to
explore everything this strange book has
to offer
just the main story beats if you'd like
me to cover any aspects that have
interested you in this video
do write them down in the comments below
a theme across this book
and many other new testament texts is
that jesus will return
and bring with him the second coming and
a fiery cataclysm
the very first communities of christians
believe such an event would happen in
their lifetime but when it never came to
pass
the hope was transferred to generations
after them and so on
until the present day throughout history
theologians and everyday folk have
attempted to figure out when the
apocalypse will happen
and whether there'll be any warning
signs that hint that is on its way
often as in always they get it
spectacularly wrong
and occasionally embarrass themselves in
the process just like pope sylvester
feared that the year 1000 would mark the
end of the world some worried that the
year 2000 would too
in fear of the y2k where computers would
cease to function
causing a global technological meltdown
more recently
2012 was seen as a good year for the
apocalypse misplaced fears about the
mayan calendar
led some to believe that the earth was
on a collision course with the
fictitious planet nibiru
just as the mayan calendar continued the
gregorian calendar continued
and we're still here today to my mind i
doubt that anyone can ever predict when
the end of the world is going to happen
so for now we can relax people have got
it wrong in the past
so let's hope they'll continue to get it
wrong in the future
hey thanks for watching this video
really hope you enjoyed this one is an
absolute blast to make
if you like this kind of stuff
especially this longer form video when i
subscribe
a like and a comment also go a really
long way after a bit of pause and
uploads to finish off my university
dissertation
i'm glad to say that i've graduated
thank you all for your patience
more videos to come i promise i have
plenty of videos that i've been itching
to make anyway
i look forward to seeing you next time
[Music]
goodbye
you